يوم الاثنين الماضي كان هذا المنزل مسرحا
لعمليه قتل رحب حياتها الطالب السعودي
وليد الغريبي لل 25 عاما قتلته نيكول ميري
الامريكيه ذي 19 عاما تفاصيل الحادث
ترويها لنا صاحبه المنزل التي وجدت وليد
غارقا في دماؤه في الطابق الثالث تحديدا
في الحمام صاحبه المنزل تم استدعائها على
عجل من قبل القاتلين الاخرين للمنزل قالوا
لها بانهم يسمعون صوت لبدات مخنوقه لا
يعرفون مصدرها وصلت صاحبه المنزل على عجل
وجدت نيكول ميري تنظف بطريقه غريبه تشاجرت
هي واياها وعلى الفور لكل ميري تركت
المنزل
دخلت الى سيارتها واقلعت
هنا صاحبه المنزل
حاولت ان تطلع على ماذا لا يحصل تحديدا في
الطابق الثالث وجدت باب الحمام مقفولا
حاولت بكل الطرق ان تفتحه وفي النهايه
نجحت
لتجديد غارقا في دماؤه في هذا الحمام
يصارع ويلفض نفس انفاسه الاخيره حاولت
الاتصال بالشرطه وبعد 10 دقائق تحديدا
وصلت الشرطه لتعلن وفاه وليد عند الساعه
11:00
صباحا 51 دقيقه